[Applause]
we need to shut down private prisons we
need to end cash bail because by the way
it is an economic justice issue as much
as it is a criminal justice issue
joe biden says we've got to reform
policing to the point that we
all agree everyone should face
accountability and consequence if they
break the law
and so joe says we will have a system
that bans chokeholds and carotid holes
because
george floyd might be alive today if
that were the case
[Applause]
we will have a national registry of
police officers
who break the law why because
it's not right that somebody can get
fired in one place
for doing the wrong thing and move
someone out somewhere else and get hired
joe has the courage to speak truth about
this
on the other hand you have donald trump
who stood on a stage in front of 70
million
american people at a debate and
refused to condemn white supremacists
and then doubled down and said
stand back and stand by
and here's the thing houston it's a
pattern
let's not forget he came to fame
as a candidate for president by
questioning the legitimacy of america's
first black president
let's not forget that at
charlottesville where there were
peaceful
protesters protesting racial injustice
in america where a young woman died
and on the other side there were
neo-nazis
wearing swastikas carrying tiki torches
spewing racist and anti-semitic
slurs and when the president of the
united states was asked about it
he said there were five people on both
sides
a president who called mexicans rapists
and criminals a president who came into
office and as one of his first orders of
business
put in place a muslim ban
we are better than this
we are better than this and we deserve
better than this
[Applause]
we need a president who reflects
who we really are
a president who understands within the
beautiful
diversity of who we are wherever you
live
whatever you race whatever language
grandmother speaks
that we need a president who sees that
we all have so much more in common
than what separates us and ends this
continuous thing that's about trying
china's soul hate
and division we need a joe biden who
wants to come in
and unify us as a nation
[Applause]
and then when we look at the crises
there is the crisis of this climate
crisis
right now you know texas knows what i'm
talking about
you all know i come from california look
the west
has been burning from california with
these wildfires to oregon and washington
colorado
i've met with families who've been
evacuated because their homes have
burned to the ground
i've met with firefighters who are
fighting fires while their
own home is burning in fact my
brother-in-law's a firefighter
you look at what's happening the
neighbors to texas and the gulf states
we are now on the fifth named storm
this year hitting the gulf states you
know why you name the storm because it's
really bad
so now this one is zeta with all due
respect to my
sisters there you go
but it's a crisis we're dealing with in
the midwest
the storms have caused flooding to the
point that farmers have lost a whole
season of crops and so joe
understands this and joe says hey
we need to embrace the science like
let's deal with this let's deal with the
fact
it literally represents an existential
threat to who we are
as a species joe knows that if you deal
with this in terms of investment in
renewable energies
and investment in the technologies that
are about solar and wind power texas is
one of the leaders
that you've also invested in jobs
millions of jobs good paying jobs
jobs that will be the function of the
training programs from
the building trades and the carpenters
and the electricians
joe knows that joe has the courage to
say the
clock is ticking on this and we need to
approach this with a sense of urgency
joe knows
that this is also an environmental
justice issue which is a civil rights
issue
which is a human rights issue when you
look at the fact that of all
areas in our country with poor air
quality 70
of the occupants in those areas are
people of color
joe knows and we've met with the folks
in flint
joe understands the seriousness of this
crisis
on the other hand
you have donald trump who
when interviewed by a journalist about
what was going
on with the wildfires in california so
the journalists asking something like
you know that these wildfires are raging
and you know the scientists are saying
this thing and that thing about just the
the human behaviors are contributing to
these extreme weather conditions
what do you have to say
the president of the united states
who is also the commander-in-chief
responds to the question by saying
science doesn't know
he's the president of the united states
well science does know mr president and
science knows so much that the leading
science
publication has endorsed joe biden for
president of the united states
[Applause]
so there you go and these are just a few
of the
the challenges that we are facing as a
nation
and that brings me to this moment which
is the last day here in texas for early
voting
and now getting prepared for in four
days
the election on tuesday november 3rd
and you know people have been asking me
like they asked all of us because i'm
sure they've been asking you because you
are leaders among this and so
that people probably come up to you and
saying well why should i vote
why should i vote and you know i think
there are three reasons
that people should vote
one is to honor
the ancestors
let's honor the ancestors this year we
lost
the great john lewis
who is now among the ancestors and who
while
a hero on this earth shed blood on that
edmund pettus bridge
for our right to vote let's honor the
ancestors let's honor
the fact that we just celebrated the
100th anniversary of the 19th amendment
and all those suffragettes in their wife
just marching
marching and shouting for a woman's
right to vote and then
you know let's always always be accurate
about history
black women can vote until 1965
but it's time to and we can now i heard
that
so let's honor the ancestors to vote
reason number two everything is at stake
everything you can go down the list we
just discussed
you can talk about our public schools
joe and i are going to
triple title one funding understanding
that our children
are in these schools with incredible
god-given talent but they need the
resources to achieve their talent
we are going to put 70 billion dollars
into hbcus because as a proud graduate
of an hvcu i know what they do
to contribute to national and
international leadership
you know
so much is at stake
it is at stake that right now there are
545 children
who because of the united states
government
don't know where their parents are
because of the child
separation policy at the border which is
a human rights offense that was
committed by the united states
government
what is at stake is creating a pathway
to citizenship
renewing a promise to our dreamers
by renewing daca protections
everything is at stake so that's reason
number two to vote
reason number three so
i've been traveling all over the country
i've been in north carolina and george
and florida in fact i'm going to florida
when i leave here
ohio you name it and um
all over our country and especially
after 2013 when the supreme court gutted
shelby beholder that at the voting
rights act
we've seen states you know at least two
dozen states
put in place policies and laws that have
been
designed to suppress the vote in north
carolina in fact the court that reviewed
their law
said it was written with quote surgical
precision
to make it difficult for black people in
north carolina to vote
around our country we have seen policies
and laws
that have been designed to to make it
hard for folks to vote you know here in
texas where they
pulled up the drop boxes and so in
harris county with 11 million people
there is
one dropbox are you kidding me
in states where if people vote by mail
well you gotta
fill out the thing the ballot and put it
in one envelope then you gotta be sure
to put it in the second envelope
and then be sure you sign that envelope
or get somebody to sign it for you
the president of the united states on
the debate stage who
openly solicited voter suppression
not to mention they're messing with the
post office
i mean the post office god knows where
are you the post office
like the nicest people
they're messing with the post office
and so all of this has to lead us to ask
the question why
are so many powerful people
trying to make it so difficult and
confusing
for us to vote and i think we know the
answer
the answer is because they know
our power they know
our power they know our power
to stand up and exercise our voice
through our vote they know that we
know that when we vote things change
they know when we
vote we win
so let's not let anyone not
this election or ever take our power
from
us let's not anyone not let anyone
make us feel a concern
for our anxiety about whether we
matter let's not give anybody that power
over us to ever make us question
we have the power
we were born with it they didn't give it
to us it wasn't granted to us
it is ours
so we know we have to do we have to get
everybody out
in four days on november 3rd that
tuesday
and make sure that especially during
this pandemic when people are
feeling alone and we got a social
isolate and people are wearing a mask
you can't really see their full face and
you're just feeling like
i don't know feeling kind of alone let's
remind people
they are not alone and we are all in
this together
[Applause]
and then my final point is this
this moment will pass
this moment will pass and
years from now our children
our grandchildren others
they will look at us they will look in
our eyes
each one of us and they will ask
us where were you
at that moment in time
and what i know we will be able to tell
them
is so much more than just how we felt
at this moment we will tell them
what we did
we will tell them we were hanging out
this one
friday evening in houston with pamela
and all these incredible
elected officials we will tell them
to comment we will tell them tno's
graced us with her
presence we will tell them that we were
organizing folks
that we were telling them what was at
stake we were reminding them of the
sacrifice of our ancestors we will tell
them
that we called and we text and we
emailed everybody multiple times till
they got sick of us but they got over it
and we will tell them we elected
joe biden the president of the united
states
thank you houston thank you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign